oui c'est la direction du musée Grévin
effectivement le comité de direction je
ne suis pas toute seule
il y en a il y en a d'autres bien sûr
oui c'est un choix douloureux mais ce
choix il a été fait égard surtout à la
famille ou victimes dans un dans un
premier temps
surtout pour cela ensuite certes on a
reçu beaucoup de messages
contre
Pierre Palmade
bon et c'est vrai que c'est des
décisions difficiles et je vous cache
pas qu'en plus le musée Grévin comme
vous le savez c'est plutôt un lieu de
divertissement en général là pour parler
que de bonheur et là c'est un sujet qui
est particulièrement douloureux ça
faisait que maintenant
il est entré comme vous voyez avec avec
Muriel Robin il y a deux ans exactement
c'est ça alors qui alors vous êtes
pratiquement tous d'accord avec la
décision du musée Grévin Gilles Verdez
d'accord oui il y avait pas d'autres
solutions le musée Grévin est à l'écoute
effectivement aussi de ses visiteurs et
il commençait même à y avoir parmi les
visiteurs quand ils arrivaient au début
devant Pierre Palmade un peu de réaction
choquée ou meurtri donc il fallait le
retirer peut-être à titre provisoire
voire même plus mais en tout cas il ne
pouvait plus rester comme une star
regardée par des gens qui l'admiraient
au musée Grévin il y avait une
incompatibilité pour moi
le principe d'un musée quand c'est des
tableaux c'est des tableaux qu'on vient
admirer et quand c'est comme Grévin le
musée Grévin c'est des gens qu'on admire
donc on va on peut décider décemment pas
laisser quelqu'un qui est plongé dans
une telle tourmente dramatique c'est
impossible on peut pas le conserver
c'est on peut pas admirer mais Pierre
Palmade pour ce qui est devenu
malheureusement bah c'est vrai Grévin
enfin l'idée même de Grévin c'est de
représenter les personnalités populaires
dans le bon sens du terme de belles
personnes on essaie par leur talents par
parce qu'ils sont dans dans la vie
bon là c'est bon certes monsieur Palma
des malade c'est une addiction et c'est
terrible mais c'est vrai quand ça
entraîne comme ça des victimes
ce que j'ai aimé moi Véronique dans ce
que vous avez dit vous avez dit tout de
suite on l'a fait pour la famille des
victimes ça vous avez dit vous l'avez
fait pour les familles des victimes mais
ça je pense que il y a l'explication
elle est tellement limpide là-dessus toi
Raymond tu es pas d'accord avec le avec
le non moi je vais faire un peu le côté
provocateur parce que d'abord j'adore le
musée Grévin j'y étais plusieurs fois ça
c'est génial il y a pas de souci
là-dessus mais je vous avais dit on a
reçu beaucoup de messages alors bien sûr
qu'on pense à la famille et bien sûr que
ce qu'a fait Pierre Palmade c'est un
pardonnable vous les gens parlent de
malades pour moi il est pas malade il
est juste calmé depuis 30 ans et malade
c'est quand tu as le cancer c'est quand
tu as une maladie dans des générative
des maladies c'est autre chose c'est
autre chose les maladies c'est pas moi
pour moi pour moi quand tu te calmes
depuis 30 ans tu es pas malade tu es
juste que tu prends maintenant faut
prendre ses responsabilités pourquoi
j'ai mis non parce que au musée Grévin
j'ai vu des gens qui étaient au musée
Grévin qu'on fait des trucs condamnés
par la justice et qui sont restés au
musée Grévin et qui aujourd'hui sont
encore au musée Grévin or moi ce qu'il a
fait Palmade impardonnable il y a des
hommes politiques qui sont musées
grévins il y a des chanteurs qui étaient
qui avaient des des penchants de
pédophilie qui était au musée Grévin il
y a des sportifs il y a plein de gens de
toute culture de tout de tout le monde
qui ont été condamnés par la justice et
qui sont au musée Grévin donc c'est pour
être un peu provocateur parce que je
vois des oui partout c'est facile pas le
mal on va j'espère qu'on va s'en occuper
pas que parce qu'il est malade j'espère
que vraiment par rapport à la famille
j'espère qu'il va payer aussi bah
malheureusement à titre d'exemple parce
qu'on peut pas rouler camés c'est pas
possible mais j'ai mis un nom parce que
je trouve que c'est facile de dire parce
que les gens ont dit alors j'ai enlevé
Pierre Palmade on en a marre un peu de
gens ont dit c'est vrai les gens disent
mais il y avait quand même des gens qui
sont musées Grévin reconnaissez-le qui
ont été condamnés par la justice et qui
sont encore
sûr avec un la perte d'un bébé et bien
évidemment une famille avec une famille
bien évidemment mais c'était juste pour
mettre un nom parce que je vois tout le
monde mais oui voilà moi je veux que moi
je veux que je vous dire même vous
parler de malade tant que Pierre Palma
reste assigné et Michel Marie peut nous
dire tant qu'il reste assigner à
l'hôpital c'est des jours de prison qui
fera en moins c'est vrai ou pas c'est
des jours de prison qui va faire en
moins c'est reste 2 mois à l'hôpital ça
veut dire que s'il prend 5 mois à 6 mois
c'est ce que j'ai entendu partout dans
les infos je crois que 2 mois
j'ai entendu que à l'hôpital c'est comme
s'il était en prison il a raison alors
alors moi pour moi je vous le redis ici
je vous le redis aussi tous les gens qui
sont comme Pierre Palmade qui roulent
sous calme depuis 30 ans qui roule sous
alcool depuis quand il y a un drame
j'étais malade non t'es pas malade c'est
pas ça être malade être malade c'est une
maladie une vraie maladie ça c'est peine
vraiment pour toi c'est pas une vraie
maladie pour moi non quand tu t'en fous
plein de PIF tout le weekend parce que
tu as les moyens de dépenser de l'argent
d'acheter de la cam de faire des fêtes
pas de problème
7 même les pauvres faites vos fêtes il y
a pas de problème mais quand il arrive
un drame ne venez pas me sortir l'excuse
de la maladie
il est malade et responsable là
n'empêche pas
moi je comprends tout à fait ce que veut
dire ces gens-là sont conscient dans sa
tête pour lui il considère pas ça comme
une maladie
considère pas ça comme une maladie quoi
une maladie pour Raymond c'est quelque
chose qui tombe dessus c'est-à-dire que
tu as deux mains tu as les destin fait
que tu as une maladie incurable et qui
souffre d'addiction et qui ce soir sont
heurtés parce que vous leur dites que
non ils sont pas malades ils sont
malades aussi
mais moi je me dis que voilà peut-être
qu'il faut se faire aider peut-être je
dis tout voilà je dis tout mais si
pendant 20 ans tu peux te déplacer
prendre de la cam alors peut-être que tu
es mal entouré peut-être qu'autour de
toi ça va pas tu es mal entouré tu as
pas d'amis parce que tous les gens qui
se qui se proclament hamides Pierre
Palmade aujourd'hui mais qui l'ont
laissé pendant dans cette merde jusqu'à
temps qu'on en arrive à ce jour-là là ne
me dites pas que vous êtes ses amis vous
n'êtes pas ses amis moi si demain j'ai
un ami qui qui est malade comme vous
dites je laisse pas là-dedans je vais je
vais le sortir de là-dedans mais ça si
on peut rien faire benjaminer
correctement
si on peut rien faire je suis d'accord
avec toi tu as des faits comme ça on ne
peut rien faire faut assumer je suis
d'accord pas se cacher avec le dépasse
voilà j'ai mon meilleur ami qui est dans
cet état là je ne pourrais rien faire
pour lui parce que je suis pas son
d'accord de la famille j'ai pas les
moyens d'agir et c'est proche et je
reconnais quelques-uns et en particulier
crois-moi ils ont tout essayé et ils
n'ont jamais réussi c'est la vie s'il
arrive un drame c'est la vie d'accord
les gens n'ont pas payé parce que des
gens font la fête on se droguant on va
en prenant de l'alcool en faisant les
gens n'ont pas payer les gens qui ont
rien qui ont rien fait n'ont pas payé le
fils de ce restaurateur qui a arrêté au
feu rouge il a rien fait il sort du
travail il se fait percuter par un mec
qui a volé une bagnole drogué alcoolisé
n'a pas à payer on n'a pas payé jamais
jamais
du vin et je prenais le camion après moi
je l'ai dit cette époque là c'est fini
on est en 2023 avant on roulait moi
quand j'ai eu le permis je roulais à 180
c'est fini maintenant c'est terminé on
où on assume de vivre avec les autres et
on se dit qu'on aussi on dépend des
autres et qu'on doit protéger les autres
ou alors on dit c'est le bordel on a
rien à et on roule avec un permis
d'un autre pays on roule à 200 et on
paye plus rien et on fout le bordel non
on fait on fout pas le bordel moi moi je
vous le redis là je vous le redis là
parce que j'étais pas là moi quand vous
avez battu toutes les j'étais pas là moi
quand il y a eu la faire Palmade toute
la semaine dernière j'étais pas là j'ai
pas parlé moi je vous le dis Pierre
Palmade n'est pas malade c'est tout
point 30 ans je vivrai le Banana Café à
l'époque dans les Halles en 1997 je le
livret je le voyais sortir en me disait
c'est Pierre Palmade il sortait déjà à
quatre pattes complètement défoncé le
Banana Café chez Tony Gomes je livrais à
l'époque j'allais à 6h du matin pour
livrer me dites pas que les mecs moi les
maladies pour moi c'est maladie des
enfants c'est le cancer c'est des c'est
des maladies Fatalis comme a dit Cyril
ça tombe dessus ça c'est malade faut les
aider ces gens là faut les soigner
maintenant qui passe entre les gouttes
tant d'années qui aident aussi des gens
qui ont dit
mais qui tu passes entre les gouttes
pendant 30 ans ok mais le jour où tu tue
quelqu'un au volant il y a pas de cadeau
alors il y a pas d'hôpital il y a pas de
cadeau c'est terminé Grévin donc c'est
vous regardez vos pancarte si on vous
demande pas grand chose merci euh non
mais c'est vrai euh le musée Grévin vous
êtes tous d'accord pour dire parce que
ils ont bien fait de retirer la voilà la
statue de de Pierre Palmade Véronique
voilà ils ont pris la décennie monsieur
n'est pas d'accord mais c'est je
comprends c'est comme un peu le les on
reçoit Grévin environ 800 000 visiteurs
par an donc sur les 800000 autant de
tête au temps d'avis autant d'amour pour
un seul et telle personnalité qu'il y
ait des personnalités aussi c'est vrai
que peut-être que le musée il y aurait
peut-être plus que 10 personnes dans le
musée si on avait certains peut-être roi
de France ou enfin bon et j'en passe
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un tel qu'en
général en tout cas au départ on essaie
de faire en sorte que les personnes qui
rejoignent grève vins comme très bientôt
d'ailleurs je vous donne un petit scoop
si vous voulez si je peux me permettre
pour donner un petit peu de ma chérie de
guetter dans ce monde de brut et bien
nous allons accueillir le footballeur
Antoine Griezmann tout début mars et
voici
une très belle personne
[Rires]
c'est un super pote à moi je l'adore
Antoine peut-être que pour l'occasion on
déplacera on déplacera le personnage
parce que là il est plus proche de
Killian
[Rires]
on parlait de Michael Jackson tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il n'y a aucune
personnalité française au musée Grévin
qui accusait d'avoir tué un bébé qui
l'aurait fait récemment donc je ne
comprends pas qu'on soit encore à
prendre la défense de Palmade et qui est
des noms autour de la table comment qui
en vrai il y en a qu'un de se prendre en
photo avec Pierre Palma musée Grévin qui
a envie de moi qui a envie de voir ses
sketchs aujourd'hui et de rire de ses
parents personne et je rigolais pas déjà
avoir moi souvent du tribunal médiatique
du tribunal de l'opinion mais là désolé
il a reconnu qu'il avait pris de la
drogue il a reconnu qu'il avait pris le
volant donc oui là il faut le condamner
moralement et c'est ce que fait le
tribunal médiatique et de l'opinion et a
juste titre personne n'a envie de poser
à côté de cette statue aujourd'hui
c'est une affaire tellement tragique
effectivement enfin même d'en parler
d'en reparler
c'est lourd tu as raison alors il était
dans la même salle que Robert De Niro la
famille de Pierre Palmade on en parle
pas mais je pense que quelque chose qui
est également tragique la famille il y a
beaucoup de statuts il y a beaucoup il y
a beaucoup de statues qui sont retirés
en fonction de l'époque ou de
l'actualité l'année dernière les statues
de Vladimir Poutine et Donald Trump ont
été retirés voilà
Vladimir Poutine absolument a été
retirée au début de
conflit avec lui il est à côté de Robert
De Niro Simone Veil Gérard Depardieu et
Muriel Robin
[Musique]
par rapport à toutes les surprises
évidemment qui doit être retiré je pense
comme toi en revanche son œuvre de
Palmade bien sûr désolé aujourd'hui
Palmade malgré tout ce qu'on a dit et ce
qui tu peux pas dire
un artiste
a été drôle bien sûr c'était un mec
c'était un génie de l'écriture
exactement
ça talent extraordinaire
pour moi
et pour Muriel il est incroyable après
je suis pas sûr qu'un directeur de
chaîne programme tout de suite des
sketchs avec personne
de décompression au vu de tout ce qui
arrive à part nous si on peut se tromper
de cassette sur C8 voilà mais sinon les
autres non oui et d'ailleurs le soir de
la faire ou le lendemain il y avait un
classement du Maurice sur France 3 ils
ont directement mis présenter parce que
vous avez pas le temps de remonter le
programme en disant ce programme a été
réalisé avant l'affaire Palma donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un malaise on peut
pas aujourd'hui programmer un film ou un
spectacle avec ce qui n'enlève rien à
son œuvre et à la qualité sonore
évidemment Delphine bien sûr oui encore
une fois bon je suis d'accord avec
Gilles parce qu'en fait momentanément on
peut l'enlever alors peut-être pas
définitivement le temps que tout soit
jugé bien qu'on s'est l'issue de ce qui
va se passer mais déjà momentanément je
pense que ce que c'est sage d'avoir fait
ça et au moins ça ça éteint un peu le
polémique et la polémique et le feu déjà
chez vous quoi merci si vous avez très
bien parler tout à l'heure j'aime bien
vous êtes très apaisé quand vous parlez
de ça et c'est quand même apaisant parce
que enfin c'est c'est compliqué
[Rires]
très très douloureux et pas facile
avec lui et tout je suis sûr qu'il est
assez ça donc bien sûr on rencontre
toujours les comme vous le savez
personnalité qui qui rejoignent Grévin
mais voilà c'est une expérience
incroyable d'ailleurs je voulais le dire
et Musée Grévin je suis j'adore ce musée
voilà j'ai deux musées Grévin et tu
sauts